Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Seven, Part Two.
Greenland's self-government.
Until 1953, Greenland was a colony under Denmark.
With the constitutional amendment in 1953, Greenland came under the constitution on an equal footing with Denmark and the Faroe Islands.
Greenland and Denmark agreed in 1978 to establish home rule, hjemmestyre, for Greenland.
After a referendum, Greenland got home rule by law in 1979, which meant that Greenland gradually in the following years took over responsibility for, and the possibility of passing its own laws in, a number of areas, for example social policy, taxes and duties, and education.
In 2009 the home rule arrangement was replaced by a self-government arrangement, selvstyre, which gave Greenland the possibility of getting self-determination in even more areas.
This applies, among other things, to the legal system and the management of resources and raw materials in the subsoil.
It was also established that the Greenlanders are a people in their own right with title to full independence when they themselves wish it.
Greenland's national day is the 21st of June, because it is the year's longest and brightest day.
The self-government arrangement therefore came into force on the 21st of June 2009, and the Greenlandic flag was hoisted for the first time on the 21st of June 1985.
It is called in Greenlandic Erfalasorput, which means "our flag".
The flag's colours are red and white as in Dannebrog.
The circle in the flag symbolises the rising sun in the white Greenlandic landscape.
The flag is widely used in Greenland.
The self-government consists of Greenland's parliament, Inatsisartut, which is an elected and legislative assembly, and an administration led by Greenland's government, Naalakkersuisut.
The government corresponds to a government and has the political leadership.
The parliament has 31 members, elected for four years at a time.
The chair of the government is elected by the parliament.
The parliament passes the laws in all areas the self-government has taken over.
These include social services, education, health service, taxes and duties, housing, commercial fishing and hunting, raw materials, municipal matters, environment, culture and leisure, and infrastructure.
Greenland receives in 2025 an economic grant from the Danish state of a little over four billion kroner a year, which covers a good half of the self-government's expenses.
Fishing, especially of shrimp, is the most important export income source for Greenlandic society.
With the self-government arrangement from 2009 it was established that income from raw material activities in Greenland goes to Greenland's self-government.
At the same time it was decided that such income should lead to a reduction in the Danish state's grant to Greenland.
The main industries in Greenland are fishing and tourism.
The traditional trapper trade, where people lived by catching not least seals, is by contrast dying out.
Greenland became, as part of the Kingdom of Denmark, a member of the EF, now the EU, in 1973, but after a referendum in Greenland was withdrawn again in 1985.
Greenland's cultural life.
Greenland has a rich cultural life, which stretches from traditional drum dance to modern rock music.
The age-old Greenlandic legends are written down and taught in schools.
In addition there is a widespread production of handicrafts carved from bones and teeth of the animals in and around Greenland.
Hans Lynge, who lived from 1906 to 88, is regarded as one of the most significant personalities within Greenlandic visual art and literature.
Hans Lynge was also politically active, a critic of Denmark's influence on Greenland, and a champion of greater Greenlandic independence.
His art is marked by a strong love for the original Greenlandic cultural heritage and the Inuit's traditional way of life.
He is especially known for the novel Ersinngitsup piumasaa, "The Will of the Invisible", from 1938, which is about revenge and the conflict between traditional honour and modern conscience.
In 2021 the Greenlandic author Niviaq Korneliussen, born 1990, received the Nordic Council's Literature Prize for the novel Naasuliardarpi, "Valley of Flowers", from 2020.
The book is about social and psychological problems among young Greenlanders and their feeling of belonging neither in traditional Greenlandic culture nor in a modern big city like Copenhagen.
And about the inability and unwillingness of politicians, authorities, families and friends to help them.
Christianity plays a significant role in Greenland.
The church in Greenland is part of the Danish national church, but belongs under Greenland's self-government.
Greenland has its own bishop.
The church service in Greenland takes place in Greenlandic, and a special Greenlandic tradition has developed for how hymns are sung in the churches.
Here is your recap for Episode Seven.
The realm community's official name is Kongeriget Danmark; the constitution applies in all three parts; Greenland and the Faroe Islands each elect two members of the Folketing.
Foreign and security policy and monetary policy are decided by Denmark.
In 2005, Greenland and the Faroe Islands got the possibility to negotiate certain international agreements.
Greenland is the world's largest island, 2.1 million square kilometres, 98 percent of the realm.
About 83 percent, so roughly 80 percent, is covered by ice all year; the Inland Ice is up to 3,400 metres thick.
The highest point is Gunnbjørn Fjeld, 3,694 metres.
About 57,000 live there, about 20,000 in Nuuk.
The Inuit immigrated about 1200.
Hans Egede came in 1721 and founded Godthåb in 1728.
The Royal Greenland Trading Department had its monopoly from 1776 to 1950.
In 1941, Henrik Kauffmann made the agreement with the USA.
Thule, in the early 1950s, was renamed Pituffik Space Base in 2023.
Greenland was a colony until 1953; home rule was agreed in 1978 and came into force in 1979; self-government came on the 21st of June 2009, which is also Greenland's national day.
The flag Erfalasorput was first hoisted on the 21st of June 1985.
The parliament Inatsisartut has 31 members.
The Danish grant in 2025 is a little over four billion kroner.
Fishing, especially shrimp, is the main export, and fishing and tourism are the main industries.
Greenland left the EF in 1985.
Today neither Greenland nor the Faroe Islands is part of the EU, although Denmark is.
Greenland's church is part of the Danish national church, with its own bishop.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
When did the law on home rule in Greenland come into force?
Option A: 1949.
Option B: 1979.
Option C: 2009.
[DA] Hvornår trådte loven om hjemmestyre i Grønland i kraft?  A: 1949  |  B: 1979  |  C: 2009
The answer is B: 1979.
It appeared in the November 2020 and June 2021 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: 1979
Question 2.
Are Greenland and the Faroe Islands part of the EU?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Er Grønland og Færøerne en del af EU?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the November 2022 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 3.
Which symbol is part of Greenland's flag?
Option A: A cross.
Option B: A triangle.
Option C: A circle.
[DA] Hvilket symbol indgår i Grønlands flag?  A: Et kors  |  B: En trekant  |  C: En cirkel
The answer is C: A circle.
It appeared in the May 2024 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: En cirkel
That's the end of this part.
Well done.